let's think about the limit of the
square root of 100 plus x minus the
square root of x as x approaches
infinity and i encourage you to pause
this video and try to figure this out on
your own
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it so
first let's just try to think about it
before we try to manipulate this
algebraically in some way
so what happens is x gets really really
really really large as x approaches as x
approaches infinity
well even though this hundred is a
reasonably
a reasonably large number as x gets
really large billion trillion trillion
trillions even larger than that trillion
trillion trillion trillions you can
imagine that the hundred in this under
the radical sign starts to matter a lot
less as x approaches really really large
numbers the square root of 100 plus x is
going to be approximately the same thing
as the square root of x so for
for really
really
large
large x's
we can reason that the square root of a
hundred plus x is going to be
approximately equal to the square root
of x
and so in that reality we are going to
really really really large x's in fact
there's nothing larger we can keep
increasing x's that these two things are
going to be roughly equal to each other
so it would it's reasonable to believe
that the limit as x approaches
infinity here is going to be zero you're
subtracting this from something that is
pretty similar to that but let's
actually do some algebraic manipulation
to feel better about that instead of
this kind of hand wavy argument about
the hundred not mattering as much when x
gets really really really large and so
let me rewrite this expression and see
if we can if we can manipulate it in
interesting ways
so this is
plus x
minus
x so one thing that might jump out at
you whenever you see
one radical minus another radical like
this is well maybe we can multiply by
its conjugate and somehow get rid of the
radicals or or at least transform the
expression in some way that might be a
little bit more useful when we try to
find the limit as x approaches infinity
so let's just and obviously we can't
just multiply it by anything arbitrary
in order to not change the value of this
expression we can only multiply it by 1.
so let's multiply it by a form of one
but a form of one that helps us that is
essentially made up of its conjugate so
let's multiply this
let's multiply this times
times the square root
of a hundred
plus x plus
the square root of x
over the same thing
square root
of 100 plus x plus the square root of x
now notice this of course is exactly
equal to 1. and the reason why we like
to multiply by conjugates is that we can
take advantage of differences of squares
so this is going to be equal to in our
denominator we're just going to have
we're just going to have the square root
of 100 let me write it this way actually
plus x
plus the square root of x and our
numerator
we have
the square root
of 100 plus x
minus the square root of x
times
this thing
times square root of
100 plus x plus
the square root of x now right over here
we're essentially multiplying a plus b
times a minus b will produce a
difference of squares so this is going
to be equal to
this top part right over here
is going to be equal to is going to be
equal to
this
let me do this in a different color
it's going to be equal to this thing
squared
minus
this thing
minus that thing squared so what's 100
plus x squared well that's just 100 plus
x
plus x and then what square root of x
squared well that's just going to be x
so
minus x and we do see that this is
starting to simplify nicely all of that
over
the square root
of 100 plus x plus the square root of x
and these x's x minus x will just be
nothing and so we are left with a
hundred over the square root of a
hundred plus x plus the square root of x
so we could rewrite the original limit
as the limit
the limit as x approaches infinity
instead of this we've just algebraically
manipulated it to be this
so the limit as x approaches infinity of
100 over
the square root of 100
plus x
plus the square root of x
and now it becomes much clearer we have
a fixed numerator this numerator just
stays at 100 but our denominator right
over here is just going to be it's just
going to keep increasing it's going to
be unbounded so if you're just
increasing this denominator while you
keep the numerator fixed you essentially
have a fixed numerator with an ever
increasing or a super large or an
infinitely large denominator so that is
going to approach that is going to
approach zero which is consistent with
our original intuition